once a standard way of settling
disagreements duels were not all pistols
at dawn this is a short history of
unusual duels sometimes quick thinking
could avoid a duel altogether the duel
the captain versus the Creole a
disagreement over cards followed by a
punch in the nose the Creole had quite a
bit of dueling experience the captain
had none the Creole challenged the
captain choose your weapons
the captain thought for a moment waylynn
harpoons at 20 paces after seeing the
captain demonstrate his harpoon throwing
technique the Creole immediately called
off the duel the victor the captain with
an excellent choice of weapons this has
been a short history of unusual duels
no of other unusual duels let us know in
the comments